here in this video we will showcase all
the raptor species in the jurassic movie
franchise we will include a couple of
the sub-species of velociraptors the two
type of hybrids and also two more
raptors that will be seen in the
upcoming dominion movie as well as
another one that is rumored to be
included in it but as of now there has
been no confirmation
so that's seven raptor species in total
anyway do subscribe before we get into
the video now let's do this thing
number one the velociraptor the island
nubla species the most famous dinosaur
aside from the t-rex the term
velociraptor is used in the jurassic
park universe to refer to the genus of
dino knickers velociraptors have a major
role in all five movies before the
jurassic park movie aired most people
never heard of raptors before we like to
believe that there were two types of
velociraptors in the franchise the
island nubla species is the common one
that has been seen in four of the five
movies
they were five to six feet tall and
twelve to fourteen feet long
hyper-intelligent and a packed animal
that can run as fast as a cheetah and
has featherless body with a narrow
snotted head with sharp teeth they also
have sharp talons and claws on both
forelimbs and hind limbs
number two the velociraptor the isla
sauna species the second variety or type
of velociraptors are the one from the
second island which is isla sauna
they are the raptors seen in jurassic
park 3 and they have various color
palettes the upper half of their bodies
is purple with the colors strewn around
it the males of these raptors brought
quills on the top of their heads
they have head crests that are more
elongated and pointed skulls in general
they were also fast hyper-intelligent
and has more or less the same features
as the israeli species but are a bit
smaller around 5 feet tall and 11 to 12
feet long
they were also the first to be seen to
communicate in more advanced form
amongst themselves
number three the indoraptor the first
hybrid raptor that we see in the movie
screens is the indoraptor and this was
seen in jurassic world fallen kingdom it
resembles the indominus rex in
appearance although its body length is
about half of that its predecessor it
has a velociraptor like talons and its
hue is mostly black with a golden yellow
stripe going from the base of its neck
to its tail the interrupter like the
indominus rex has four fingers an
opposable thumb and three primary digits
the shape of its skull is similar to
that of the tyrannosaurus rex and it
also has night vision
this raptor is 10 feet tall and 24 feet
long it was the only one of its kind and
was killed by blue the velociraptor in
the end of fallen kingdom
number four the scorpius rex this one is
actually the first hybrid dinosaur
created in the jurassic franchise
chronologically the scorpius rex are
smaller than the indominus rex somewhat
larger than the indoraptor it possesses
an odd shaped head and jagged uneven
teeth as well as crimson eyes with slit
pupils situated high on his head due to
its scorpion fish dna it has venomous
spines on its body it was featured in
the cartoon series camp cretaceous it
has opposable thumbs and gripping talons
just like the indoraptor and has a
semi-prehensile tail it has infrared
vision which allows it to see the heat
signature of its prey there were two of
them who both died in the series and
both were around 26 feet long and 11
feet tall
number five the ov raptor in the
original novel of your raptor is
referenced briefly it wasn't however one
of engine's cloned dinosaurs it was also
featured in a few video games but novi
raptor was plundering a clutch of eggs
from an unknown dinosaur during a
cretaceous flashback seen in the
dominion prologue one of which dinosaur
ate in the process before being
distracted by another dinosaur skull
possibly the owner of the egg
this was the first dinosaur with
feathers that we see and it's more of a
precise description this dinosaur was
around four to six feet long
number six the atrocious raptor
this is a dramer saw theropod dinosaur
genus that lived during the late
cretaceous period in alberta canada one
feature that distinguishes this raptor
from others is its short and tall skull
with large serrations on its teeth
giving it the appearance of a bulky
snouted animal it is thought that the
across a raptor had a stronger bite
force than the other raptors or it may
have had specialized tea to bite
differently jurassic world dominion will
feature the atrocious raptor with ghost
tiger red and panthera which are the
names of four characters of these
atrocious raptors
they will face off against blue the
velociraptor and we suspect that they
are the same size as velociraptors as
well
and number seven the pyroraptor this is
the one raptor that we set is rumored to
be seen in jurassic world dominion the
pyroraptor is the first raptor species
to be positively identified in europe
this was a small fast-moving dinosaur
hunter who lived near the end of the
dinosaur era so we kind of hope that
this unique species of raptor will be
seen in the movie next year
probably chasing an eating concept
mathis
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam